what happened in 2018 is genetics has
figured out something called complex
genetics and they can now explain
Heights so height isn't due to one gene
or even a small number of genes it's a
million different changes in your genome
than really dial in your height within
an inch or so each input gives you a
millimeter plus minus in your height
that means I'm a million millimeters
tall
no sometimes it's minus
yeah
tennis it's it's like genetic tennis
back and forth plus and minuses and
minus the uh the statisticians and
mathematicians are going nuts and trying
to figure out the best way to add a
million different things together